oh we're streaming my bad
I'm not even paying attention to what's
going on
so I think we went live
uh oh yeah hey there we go all right
everybody what you just got to watch is
uh me accidentally pressing the live
button while we are still trying to set
up the uh the screen so that was fun for
you well uh we're we're a little bit
frantic here because the Twitter files
are dropping as as we sit here so you
know I come up to the studio and I see
Barry Weiss you start Sweden and I'm
like come on you know they do this thing
where the tweets go really really really
slow but we got some big Bombshells this
is uh hard proof that the Twitter exacts
like Vijaya were lying I mean again Dan
bongino Charlie Kirk among those who
were actually suppressed and Shadow
banned on Twitter hard confirmation they
even posted images
now we've known about this a bit but
this is direct confirmation of them
lying a lot of this stuff we we've seen
and it's always an accident right now we
know it's not an accident there were
stories about Shadow Banning I think
Ronald McDaniel had been Shadow banned
and other members of the RNC and Twitter
said oopsie it was a mistake it's always
a mistake and every single time
something was a mistake it was a mistake
it was a mistake mistake and now we know
that their engineering teams are
actually like uh no we were uh actually
doing all that on purpose so this is the
big breaking story it's currently
developing and we're going to go through
all this plus we've got a bunch of other
stories you may have briefly seen the um
the story Elon Musk is being sued
because uh well they're claiming that
he's discriminating against women
because the people who got fired were
disproportionately women relative to
like the amount of women who got fired
was a higher percentage rate than the
amount of men who got fired or whatever
I think it actually just um plays into
that Meme where Twitter before was a lot
of women and Twitter after wasn't but
Elon just said who wants to work hard
and if you don't you can leave and if
you do you can stay and now they're
suing so that one's pretty interesting
we're going to get into all that but
before we do my friends we got an
awesome sponsor head over to
surfinginternetsafe.com and support
virtual Shield download Virtual Shield
the virtual private network service if
you want to protect yourself as you're
browsing the internet a virtual private
network is a basic layer of security for
you as you're browsing the web it stops
government corporate hackers people
trying to steal your data big Tech
platforms it's a basic layer of security
head over to surfinginternetsafe.com
they say their VPN service is compatible
with all devices and allows you to
browse the web safely securely and
anonymously using their Global Network
of servers and private IPS virtual
Shield lets you browse the web
completely anonymously so big name isps
and other third parties will not be able
to Monitor and sell your internet
activity and browsing history when using
our VPN service your traffic is routed
through their secure and encrypted
servers meaning any censorship
restrictions or blocks on your internet
are bypassed it is fast and reliable and
completely free for 30 days available on
Mac Windows iPhone iPad Android Chrome
Etc does all the work for you download
it press go you're good
and it will route your internet through
their Advanced encrypted servers which
also means your Wi-Fi connection is also
encrypted blocking hackers and everyone
else from accessing any of your data so
again head over to
surfinginternetsafe.com support virtual
Shield they are the first sponsor we've
ever had so we're we're grateful for
their sponsorship of this show and you
can also go to timcast.com become a
member and support our work directly we
have a members only censored show I'm
sorry uncensored show oh man what are
they coming up for you no no it's
totally censored this one's going to be
very boring no no after the show around
11 we'll put up the uncensored members
only after show and I'm sure we'll have
some very interesting conversations as
it pertains to the election smash that
like button subscribe to the channel
share the share with your friends the
reason I say that is because joining us
today is the man who is probably uh if
there's any one person who should take
credit for the Republicans getting the
house is Scott Pressler
thank you well you know
can you hear me okay gotta grab the mic
am I in yeah yeah yeah you can move the
mic around with it when you guys
excellent yeah uh so so who are you what
do you do
uh I guess I'm a long-haired
conservative activist kind of nomadic
traveling the country and just helping
to make sure that we're defeating the
Democrats and electing Republicans
right on my story you were you've
cleaned up cities you've registered
Republicans to vote and despite the
everything we saw in the midterms
Republicans are taking the house meaning
we're getting investigation the AOC is
going to be investigated hopefully we
see investigations of Joe Biden they're
saying they're going to do it and uh I
gotta say I I think a large amount of
that credit goes to you thank you if you
weren't registering voters at the levels
you were doing and the activism you were
doing I don't know if Republican
Republicans could even take in the house
to be completely honest well and it
wasn't even like blood red Republican
areas I mean really it was Lee zeldon in
New York of all states and ballot
harvesting in California that really
gave us this narrow majority in the
house
and uh I think that says something that
let's change up our strategy and that's
in part why I'm wearing this shirt and
it's not that I'm saying that we're
gonna do anything illegal we're going to
crossover T dot every eye but we're
going to use the same tactics the
Democrats have been doing and if those
tools are at our disposal I think we
quite frankly would be foolish not to
use them to our advantage just gotta
gotta stay up on it because by the time
2024 comes around they're gonna have
other tactics you know well and let me
tell you we're going to get so good at
ballot harvesting that they're gonna try
to ban it themselves and that that's the
goal yeah you know I want them to be
like we should have never done it it's
kind of like uh Harry Reid with the
Supreme Court right they busted the
filibuster and it was thanks to Harry
Reid and I'm not talking ill of The
Departed I want to say this is nicely
and respectfully as possible it's
because of Senator Harry Reid that we
have three conservative Supreme Court
Justices today that were given to us by
President Donald Trump you know so every
tactic that the Democrat uses can be
used against them for Republican policy
well there we go all right man thanks
for for joining us we'll talk about that
and more we got Luke hanging out hey
guys my name is Luke adowski here of we
are change and uh today I'm wearing a
shirt that dropped Monday and it came in
just in perfect time for tonight's
Twitter file release which I'm keeping
an eye on I think we are on number 17
right now so we still got a lot to cover
the shirt reads uh Elon Musk did not
Epstein himself uh with of course the
remarks he said this past Sunday and
Monday I think it's worth noting this
and highlighting this if you agree with
that you could get the shirt on
thebestpoliticalshirts.com because you
do that's why I'm here thank you so much
for having me you know a lot of people
do political science and they talk about
politics and they think about ideas and
they write stuff on people but you're
like a political engineer that actually
is there building the thing by being on
the ground and moving pieces around it's
pretty impressive thank for coming again
Bob thank you last night I had a chance
to talk with Bryson gray at Captain at
the very end of the uh the live episode
we did a little bit after the show but
then after the after show Bryson and I
went deep for like an hour and a half on
Christianity Judaism Islam it was
fantastic he's very knowledgeable I love
you Bryson episode is not up yet though
I think it's gonna go up this weekend
we're probably gonna put it up Tim you
were mentioning maybe this weekend when
there's no other maybe tomorrow's
dropping maybe tomorrow yeah uh highly
recommend it's gonna be on timcast.com
check it out it was a great great time
and if you haven't got a copy of my book
yet writing in the dark
it's really not it's very weird it was
just like you wrote it in the dark
literally in my car when I was homeless
in New York at a very dark period of my
life so there's a metaphor there you
know if you haven't ever if you ever
want to get to see like some of the
inner workings man you can go pick up
one of those on Amazon writing in the
dark by Ian Crossland what's happening
Kelly um I'll second what you said Ian I
think that Bryson gray after after show
was pretty great so once we have that up
on Tim Cass I'll shortly tweet it out um
but yeah please check it out I'm Kellen
filling in with uh filling in for search
and I'm ready to get started yeah Kellen
and serge were with us last it was the
four of us and us actually Bryson's
girlfriend came in at one point I was
talking to it was really cool really
awesome let's get into this big news
ladies and gentlemen we've got the
Twitter thread from Barry Weiss the
Twitter files part two Twitter secret
blacklists I Will Not Waste Your Time Dr
J batachara charya was arguing that
covid lockdowns would harm children he
was placed on a Trends Blacklist and
also has this flag recent abuse strike
whatever that means then we have Dan
bongino who was search blacklisted and
he also had something called a
notification Spike I don't know what
that means you can see he had no strikes
but they put him on a blacklist that
look and and it says multiple accounts
Twitter blue verified not safe for work
view I wonder what spma means Charlie
Kirk do not amplify recent abuse strike
and notification Spike multiple accounts
not safer work view interesting
what does that mean multiple accounts
are they accusing these individuals of
personally operating multiple accounts
sounds like it but I think that that's a
bannable offense right or maybe it's
because he's got like you know Turning
Point USA is his organization so he's in
charge of several different accounts
Twitter denied that they Shadow banned
people they said that they didn't do it
and they certainly didn't do it on on
ideology but then the funny thing is you
get this story first definitely dot
Twitter insists it's not Shadow Banning
conservatives and then I think is this
one weird here Twitter appears to have
fixed Shadow ban of prominent
Republicans like RNC chair and Trump
Junior spokesman so that was July 25th
2018 and then this story this was July
27 2018 saying they're not they're not
doing it they're not doing it it was
updated in May uh 2021 I wonder why so
this is uh we all knew but once again
Twitter files are delivering hard proof
conservatives are being banned Shadow
banned manipulated de-amplified
de-boosted whatever and the the stories
currently developing Barry Weiss says
this is funny they did they said they
don't Shadow ban everybody they do
visibility filtering they call it VF
refers to the ability to limit the scope
of a particular tweets or individual's
discoverability to block select users
posts from ever appearing on the
trending page and from inclusion and
hashtag searches all without people
knowing I have to wonder
they did this to Dan bongino he uses
Twitter as a business for his business
is this a breach of contract if I enter
into a contract with you and you
secretly apply restrictions against me
are they breaching their contract or is
the argument going to be no no the terms
of service say that we can do all of
these things to you
I'm not familiar with the terms enough I
would imagine
because it's a free to use service
that you really don't have any recourse
to sue them if they're screwing with you
but I don't know I don't know what the
promise was check this out they this is
where it starts getting crazy quote we
control visibility quite a bit and we
control the amplification of your
content quite a bit and normal people do
not know how much we do how much we do
one Twitter engineer told us two
additional employees confirmed the group
that decided whether to limit the reach
of certain users was the Strategic
response team global escalation team or
Sr SRT get it often handled the 200
cases per day but there existed a level
Beyond official ticketing beyond the
rank and file moderators following the
company's policy on paper
that is the site Integrity policy policy
escalation support known as sip PES the
secret group included head of legal
policy head of legal policy and Trust
vijayagade the global head of trust and
safety Joel Roth subsequent CEOs Jack
Dorsey and pop parag Agarwal and others
it's where the biggest most politically
sensitive decisions got made think High
follower count controversial another
Twitter employee told us told us for
these there would be no ticket or
anything take a look at this Libs of
tick tock it says do not take action on
user without consulting the s-i-p-p-e-s
really really interesting stuff they
mentioned that rychic had been suspended
several times you can see Libs Libs of
tick tock has a recent abuse strike
notification Spike and his Trend
blacklisted two strikes high profile it
says multiple accounts not safe for work
View
so you know how much of uh how much of
this is just kind of like yeah okay we
know
uh having the receipts here I think is
absolutely important I I think there's
going to be a bigger implications here
because it wasn't just these few
accounts that we mentioned here Barry
Weiss in uh the tread number 12
specifically documents and and says how
there was 20 cases a day of individuals
being individually targeted and attacked
as Twitter was going on and publicly
saying that we were absolutely not
Shadow Banning the corporate media was
regurgitating their talking points you
could see I just retweeted uh the
official Twitter account from 2018 they
said quote people are asking us if we
Shadow ban we don't read more to get all
the facts the fact they're not they're
not facts here again this is an official
Twitter account uh tweeting this a
couple years ago gaslighting people
lying to people as they were
manipulating our social discourse and we
know that when they do this they could
decide and determine not only the
outcome of Elections but have huge major
effects on society with the power to
essentially control people's minds this
is this is next level stuff I want to I
want to talk later about uh Brittany
Greiner and uh Paul Paul Wellen is his
name right Paul Whalen am I getting it
wrong yes uh there's
um this article from Jordan Shack till I
think it is
uh outlining how the the Biden
Administration intentionally ignored
this guy and opted for Brittany Greiner
and even NBC initially reported I think
it was nbcu
that Russia said you can have one or the
other not both and so Obama was like
give us the basketball player showing
that he doesn't care about our Marines
or the people who are who are overseas
or whatever he had the option he didn't
take it
I saw that and I just felt like I need
to stress to everybody
Joe Biden does not represent you he does
not represent any of us in this room
he does not represent the Marines or the
Army he represents his cult
the president
the Democrats in the Senate and Congress
are cult members
you do not exist to them
there was no consideration for a former
Marine when they were doing a prisoner
swap with The Merchant of death an arms
dealer because Joe Biden said
why would I care about that guy I want
you to think about it this way
right now in this country what's
happening let's say that um
you uh there's a hostage situation
and you're outside and the the the
hostage taker says I'll only release one
person your daughter or John Smith and
you're like who's John Smith in the
black well he's a decorated war hero he
saved a box full of puppies the other
day give me my daughter
my point is Joe Biden when he looks at
the potential of this he doesn't think
about the American people he thinks
about his cult and his ideology and what
earns him those points with his crowd he
is not representing the United States of
America I mentioned this back during the
coveted lockdowns when Florida was not
locked down when South Dakota was not
locked down and other conservative
states were not locked down and Joe
Biden came out and said we are locking
down for these reasons and we're gonna
have to do this that or otherwise and
I'm like well who's he talking to he
keeps tweeting at me to tell me to get
my vaccine get a vaccine he's not even a
doctor yeah he's not talking to you he's
not tweeting Abby you're right he's just
talking it out and I'm reading it like
no no no not a doctor what I'm saying is
when Joe Biden came out and said
everyone we need to do these things he
wasn't talking to any of us in this room
or any of you watching
they don't see us as part of the same
country as them I think that's just a
reality and this is exemplified just so
hilariously this is the issue I have
with conservatives Time Magazine chooses
zelenski and what do conservatives do
they go I can't believe Time Magazine
chose zelenski as person of the year
it's like first of all why would you
read Time Magazine they're the ones who
published that article about fortifying
the election they don't have any real
circulation anymore they're not
culturally relevant but conservatives
view the left as culturally relevant and
as the as the the epicenter of America
and American culture for some reason and
the left views them as creepy weirdos
have nothing to do with what this
country is doing
well and I think this is how we're
different like this is where I actually
get some pushback from my followers if
I'm America First that means that I want
to put every American first even the
commies even people that disagree with
me because I value uh upholding my
citizens rights and so even with
Brittany you know I was getting pushed
back from saying it yes we do need to
secure her Freedom even if she broke
Russian law even if she doesn't stand
for the flag or doesn't stand for our
freedoms and freedom of speech and even
when some people are saying you know to
leave cities and to leave California
behind and they chose this and let them
suffer the consequences of their votes
uh no I I don't think that's an America
First perspective we need to be fighting
for Freedom everywhere now with that
being said does does that mean that I
think that we should trade The Merchant
of death and and Russian arms dealer
while the very country Russian Putin are
invading Ukraine all I can see from this
is I think there's a very real
possibility that through his connections
with his freedom now we could see Putin
uh gaining even more arms to use against
Ukraine which what does that mean from
us that means that we are going to be
sending another 74 billion dollars to
Ukraine to solve the problem that was
just exacerbated by our very president
and that's kind of where my head is at
in this and I say not another dime for
Ukraine I was already at if we're
securing Ukraine's border while we're
not securing ours why should we be
sending them any money but the the fact
of the matter is the United States is
creating a problem while also trying to
be the solution and the only people that
are suffering from this or are us
I met a guy he was I think he was a
captain in the in the Army I think I
can't remember I don't know how the
ranking stuff works but he said he
retired he was planning on uh staying in
until he was too old he wanted to be you
know a careerist or you know first of
all career and then he's in his mid-30s
and he said he was resigning his
Commission because of the wokeness
that's happening in the military
and so I see that and I'm and I'll say
it you know they're shutting down
prisons they're releasing criminals
crime is rampant and the politicians
keep like the Democrats in these cities
keep doing the same thing and I'm like
isn't it obvious at this point it's
because you are not a part of what they
are doing when they say our democracy
replace when they say our democracy
replace that with cult and then remember
that you're not a part of their cult so
when Joe Biden comes out and says these
far-right extremists are a threat to our
cult then you need to understand what
he's really saying he's not talking
about the United States he's talking
about something that excludes you
specifically yeah the United States is a
plural the United States are a thing
it's a bunch of states that are united
we are united and if if someone in the
federal government is trying to override
that and act like they're the one that
resembles the you the States United then
they're failing he's Let's uh let's
continue on with this thread here the
number 17 uh uh tweet from Barry Weiss
gets really really interesting because
now you start to see the that Twitter
was lying about their bias check this
out
Barry White says the account Libs of
tiktok which Chaya reichick began in
November 2020 and now boasts over 1.4
million followers was subjected to six
suspensions in 2022 Alone rychic says
each time she was blocked from posting
for as long as a week Twitter repeatedly
informed reichek that she had been
suspended for violating Twitter's policy
against hateful conduct but in an
internal s-i-p PES Memo from October
2022 after her seventh suspension the
committee acknowledged quote Libs of
tick tock has not directly engaged in
behavior violative of the hateful
conduct policy they were lying that's
actionable
shocker I think that's legal action
right there I think this is um right
here actual malice Libs of tick tock uh
Chaya lawsuit time if they publicly
stated you violated the kind of hateful
uh their hateful conduct policy but then
internally said you didn't that means
they knew they were lying but here's
here's here's the thing does she Sue
Elon Musk now yeah Scott you mentioned
that before the show too what's the
process of uh of a lawsuit in this
situation do you go after a previous
ownership
I would think so I mean you would have
to who was the decision maker was it
Vijaya I I would go after the individual
person as opposed to Twitter the company
because clearly all of this was done
before the Elon Musk Administration well
there's names being named here a part of
their strategic response team and the
group's name and who was heading them
and it looks like Vijaya was at the head
of many of these important decisions uh
we go back in the in the tweets and you
know the the documents are here it shows
us exactly who was making these
decisions why they were making them how
they were making them up and how a lot
of this was just absolutely arbitrary
especially when it came to hypocritical
moves especially when it came to Libs of
tick tock being doxed the the doxing of
lips of tick tock garnered what was it I
think Barry White says 10 000 likes and
that wasn't stopped but but her doing
something that they construed on the
technicality was which wasn't even uh
you know correct which they knew
1000 likes on this boxing tweet and they
said no it's fine I had someone uh post
an insane thread with an address and
Twitter told me they would not take it
down
and I was like okay whatever
then it leads to exactly what you'd
expect it to lead to they claimed their
justification for removing uh Libs of
tick tock and the suspension was
indirectly violating their policies by
tweets that delete that either intend to
in sight or LED people to then harass
so not inciting not harassing but
because she posted video and someone
else did well that's indirect so we're
gonna suspend her even though it doesn't
violate our policies however you post an
address and sorry nothing in an internal
slack message Twitter employees spoke of
using technicalities to restrict the
visibility of tweets and subjects here's
Joel Roth Twitter's then head Global
head then Global head of trust and
safety in a direct message to a
colleague in 2021
he wrote A lot of times S.I has used
technicality spam enforcement as a way
to solve a problem created by a safety
under enforcing their policies
which again isn't a problem per se but
it keeps us from addressing the root
cause of the issue which is that our
safety policies need some attention
amazing six days later in a direct
message with an employee
Roth requested more research to support
expanding quote non-removal policy
interventions like disabling engagements
and deamplification slash visibility
filtering Roth wrote the hypothesis
underlying much of what we've
implemented is that if exposure to
misinformation directly causes harm we
should use
remediations that reduce exposure and
limiting the spread and virality of the
content is a good way to do that in
other words these people are saying
your ideas lead to things that we don't
like regardless of what that may be we
are going to stop people from being able
to see what you post
and then they had the the audacity to go
publicly and say we don't chat about
conservatives
now here's a funny thing the whole time
they were doing this I was saying it's a
semantic game they'll say we we don't
Shadow ban anybody it's called
visibility filtering it's totally
different they would say we did not
Shadow ban anyone for being conservative
we Shadow ban them for misgendering
someone of course liberals and
conservatives have you know opposing
views on what misgendering is so of
course they're literally doing it based
on the political ideology or political
values of the individual yeah I didn't
punch you in the face I just threw my
fist at your your uh you know face you
know so that's technically not the same
thing right guys it's absolutely
incredulous it's absolutely like insane
Congress says uh you know Miss God a is
there a door on the front of Twitter's
building no there isn't there's no door
no there's not what do you mean there's
not well what we have is a large pane of
Glass on hinges with a handle that when
you pull it actually moves on the hinge
creating an opening for which you can
move through but it's not a door it's
like okay what
it's the deconstruction of language man
that's the game they play and all
ethically the idea that bad information
how did they phrase it how did this guy
yell phrase this the bad information get
into the other oh I don't know what he
said but he basically was insinuating
that getting misinformation will make
people evil or whatever so show them
less information but I think that's like
it's like saying that
if a virus makes you sick don't don't
expose anyone to the virus but we know
that immune system is a real thing and
you need a little bit of exposure to
enhance your immune system so that you
can handle it when it inevitably comes
around misinformation will inevitably
come around you need to be resistant to
it you'd understand it and be able to
spot it and question information when
you see it but just making it so people
don't ever get a chance to be exposed to
it is not the way to make people
stronger that's my that's my belief on
ethics on this one you know one of the
craziest things I love I love the amount
of weird Flack we're getting from all
these Lefty organizations about the yay
stuff
someone super chatted because I don't
know I may have missed it that yay said
to Alex Jones
maybe I shouldn't have singled out an
entire group of people and just pointed
out at the banks something like that
someone commented that I don't know if
he actually said that but uh if that is
the case it shows you how these
conversations actually do good it shows
how on Twitter there's that famous story
of the Westboro Baptist Church woman who
got de-radicalized by being on Twitter
and saying these things then people
countering and then eventually she was
like okay maybe I'm wrong
I I feel like what what they really want
they want villains you guys have you
seen that what's that what's that group
of Feds that marches around pretending
to be conservative activists oh yeah are
they feds
do we know that I think they glow you
think they glow so anyway look everybody
sees that group and they're like that's
not it can't be real right
they need villains they need something
to justify their their their laws that's
why they want people to get violent
don't get violent it's the one thing
they know how to how to respond to so if
they can't get it they fake it the FBI
gets a bunch gets like what 12 FBI
agents get two crack pots and then keep
elbowing them being like come on kidnap
this lady and they're like uh gas aha we
got you and then they have this big mock
trial and then try to lock these guys up
they need villains but it's essentially
what the CIA has been doing with
American foreign policy for the last few
decades all going all the way back to
the Mula hajjin in Afghanistan that
became the Taliban going back to of
course uh the rebels in north of uh Iraq
that became Isis and in Syria that of
course were there against the regime
because we needed regime change and I
could keep going on and on and on but
there's there's a long history of
setting up your opposition in order to
uh give yourself an excuse to have
um you know strict uh tougher more um
brutal force down yeah the Patriot Act
is another example of it but but these
these tweets are still coming in right
now Blair white just tweeted the Jack
Redemption Arc is over after of course
we're finding out through these uh
disclosures that Jack Dorsey was on
board uh with implementing this for
quote Civic Integrity this is not Civic
Integrity this is the destruction of of
dialogue of conversation of people being
able to honestly have conversations with
each other and they stood in the middle
of that and said no we're going to
control what goes into your mind we're
going to control what you can say and
cannot say we're going to control who
gets to see these larger ideas the best
idea won't win my idea will win and
that's just disgusting patronizing
messed up behavior of of you know Big
Brother uh Big Daddy government
controlling every aspect of your life
and that's exactly what these people I'm
just going to let everybody in on some
Insider information
um it's nothing crazy uh but I've I've
frequently hit up Jack and asked him to
come on the show he's a year ago he said
yes when when he had time it's it's been
a year so I hit him up again I'm like
you know it's about that time it's the
annual ask Jack to come and have a
conversation and I understand by like
coming out and saying this and being
critical of them the likelihood that he
actually wants to come on is low but
what I think of Jack Dorsey is that he
built a sewer and then he crawled to the
lowest point of the piping placed his
mouth firmly on the spigot and turned it
on and just let it all flow into his
body what I mean by that is in the early
days of Twitter this was a tech bro he
was like a Libertarian style Tech bro he
was the Free Speech wing of the Free
Speech party he created a platform that
just started loading up with refuse from
woke activists spouting garbled nonsense
and then he started consuming that
garbled nonsense and buying into it and
believing it and then he ended up
because the the machine was going right
down his throat vomiting all that stuff
back out into the platform so when you
have a bunch of activists demanding
censorship arguing this is the right
thing to do and you give it a little bit
eventually the only thing you see is
their arguments and then you start
buying into their argument then as the
person controlling the system you start
implementing rules based on their
arguments so from Free Speech wing of
the Free Speech party to gargling on the
refuse of voc activists and spitting it
back in their faces and everyone else's
I wonder if what he said it was his
civic responsibility or for the Civic
righteousness or whatever he said why he
was Banning and Shadow Banning I wonder
if it's because the government was like
you know it's your civic responsibility
they're there with handcuffs like dudes
what it's your civic responsibility
better do it like wink wink we're gonna
throw in prison if you don't and that's
why he's talking about decentralizing it
and creating a protocol instead of a
centralized Network because if you have
a centralized Network DEA wants to or
not the DEA whoever government agencies
are going to want to control it they're
going to try and protect it they'll call
it but I mean they want to get in there
and choose what people see and you know
what people are told Dave Rubin just
retreated his conversation that he had
with Jack Dorsey in 2020 where Jack
specifically told them that there's no
Shadow Banning based on political
beliefs I just retweeted it myself uh at
look we are changed on there on Twitter
uh but again 20 20 Dave Rubin
specifically was asking hey are you guys
Shadow Banning yes or no Jack Dorsey
responded and said no they're justifying
double speak by saying it's not a band
or anything another algorithm intake or
your app flow it's not it's ridiculous
hold on hold on there's some Nuance of
the Tweet we have to address Dave Rubin
said do you Shadow ban based on
political beliefs simple yes or no will
do and Jack said no and this is the
problem
they're using semantics to lie no it's
nothing to do with their political
beliefs you can vote for Republicans but
if you want lower taxes smaller
government believe it that there's only
two genders well then we'll ban you but
that's politics no no no no see politics
refers to who you vote for
right
those are the games they play yeah you
can ask any question and they will find
some legalese nonsensical semantic
argument as to why they're they're doing
or not doing the whatever they're
supposed to be doing or not doing well I
mean people question elections that gets
banned online I've heard and that's
total politics so obviously if you're
involved in suppressing people
questioning elections around the world
then you're involved in political
suppression get that straight well I
asked Elon when I was on the space with
him and I said
have advertisers threaten to pull money
if you didn't adhere to a certain policy
or have lawmakers threaten to introduce
legislation should you not adhere and I
wonder if that's been going on as well
you know the threatening of introducing
policy or legislation that would hurt
Twitter's ability if they didn't censor
people you know because Twitter came uh
came along when President Obama was in
office right it wasn't just under
President Trump yeah I think so 2008
maybe and so maybe he was getting some
of those pressures from democratic
control
but I I think you're right Tim it's not
necessary they do need a villain but to
expand upon it more
when we aren't the villains that they
say we are they have to create that and
then point the finger and say see see
exactly what I was talking about and
then they can use that as an opportunity
for censorship
Etc did you guys see Malcolm flex's
tweet about yay it was brilliant he was
like Yay went on with Tim pool Alex
Jones and gav McGinnis these people that
the left keeps claiming are Nazis and
none of them would agree with him on the
Jews must like it must have been very
frustrating for you talking about dude
yeah exposed Alex Jones for being
awesome that was a picture of Yale being
sitting there looking all frustrated
right right yeah I retweeted that one it
was the Bernie Sanders meme where he's
sitting there like but they put yay's
face mask over it and his jacket and the
idea is basically like I wonder if that
was the case you know if you're yay and
you're not super into politics this way
like you may have some ancillary view of
it but the activists keep saying like oh
Alex Jones is a fascist he's a Nazi and
then you're like okay so you go and hang
out with him and Alex is like no I hate
all those people I want nothing to do
with it you're like wait what
everybody told me that was the case so
this is the funny thing even Gavin
McGinnis who they claim is the far-right
white supremacist Neo-Nazi proud boys
he's telling yay to stop judging people
based on being a part of a group and a
judge him like individuals and I wonder
if what yay actually did was just
grabbing the Overton window and ripping
it as far to the right as he possibly
could
I think so he I mean he really made Alex
look like a good guy that interview made
Alex look like the defender of
righteousness man because yay was
throwing some nonsense at him and he
knew he was and Alex was just like I got
I gotta stop you there man well they're
they're one Bridge Too Far they're
desperately trying so uh there's an
article that came out it's from I think
maybe the independent or something or
Yahoo and it was like Tim Poole profited
off of yay's anti-Semitism or something
like that and then it was like because
he came on the show and said this stuff
and then I disagreed with him and we
made super chats they're arguing that it
was profiting off of hate or whatever
and I'm like or is it profiting off of
opposing hate they're just going to keep
lying they're going to keep trying to
manufacture some kind of narrative to
create Boogeyman and villains
because the only thing they have it's a
cult it's very disturbing that people
think we could create a world where
people aren't mean or cruel like that is
complete impossibility and Insanity to
think that we could suppress the human
will so much that people will just be
nice all the time I I wanna I wanna I
wanna tell you guys something
you see the project Veritas expose the
other day it's it's like this morning
when I wake up and I'm doing my morning
segment the fir I'm I'm watching the
video again because we watched the night
the other night
I just went on YouTube and I looked up
90s commercials and I was like I'm just
gonna like 15 minutes of commercials
from the 90s just to just to remember
the good old days when there were no
troubles and I'm I know my parents
probably had troubles and there was war
and stuff but I was a little kid so I'm
gonna watch these commercials forget all
about it
that was so disturbing
that this Dean was talking about how
they were giving these kids these adult
objects teaching them how to use them to
spit on them and things like that anyone
I can't even say it because you might
have kids in the room
and so I started uh I posted on Facebook
and here's the funny thing
what do you think the response is from
the left when they hear the stuff do you
think they go wow that's a bridge too
far for me I better rethink what I'm
doing no they say well he doesn't seem
at all worried about it the school seems
to stand by it it must be okay and I'm
like bro are you kidding me
as long it's it's like that that uh
that's this this I forgot I don't know
what you'd call it but the story about
when there's a fire in a room
if one person is a room by themselves
and smoke comes through they'll they'll
they'll go to the door feel the door and
go hey there's smoke there's a fire
they'll yell but if you have multiple
people in a room the smoke will go under
the door and everyone will look at each
other look confused and then ignore it
because no one's doing anything it's
like these collectivists can actually be
shown a video of a man bragging about
how cool it is that they're doing these
things to children well but nobody's mad
about it so it must be okay right and
that's just like if you're a person a
leader of strong moral fiber you're
gonna be like no I have a line that's
that's beyond for me I'm sorry
that's why we have a senate that's why
we're supposed to have a morally
righteous Senate uh says maybe that's
why they say that this this government
can't last without Christianity in it
because we need some group of leaders
that are critical thinkers that can see
it when it happened you know see like
disillusionment when it rears its ugly
head there's a couple things I want to
say about this story but this is a
family-friendly broadcast and I'm going
to save those comments for later you
know what what's your response to stuff
like that I mean you're in the political
world right uh do the voters see stuff
like that does it affect them or is it
as Tim says they see it and they're like
whatever
I I think some people
are tacitly approving of it because
they'd rather not rock the boat they'd
rather not
get into Political debates and and I
think that's wrong and and what Tim just
said really shows the necessity that we
have to speak out against it especially
we were just talking about this earlier
that this book to people who don't know
genderqueer is in schools across the
country and we've had principles we've
had school boards fight to keep it in
schools and it says things that I would
never say to a child let alone my mother
or other adults I think quite frankly I
would consider this child pornography
and this is in our schools and what
people don't know
they don't know what they don't know and
I think if people did find out that this
was in our schools that they would be
horrified and that it would actually
motivate them to get involved and I
think we saw that with Virginia and
Governor Glenn yonkin Etc but you know
even for myself I was thinking
what is My Philosophy when it comes to
being a conservative or republican or
just a I consider myself a freedom
nationalist you know we've been hearing
people say Christian nationalists no I'm
a freedom Nationalist and usually what I
say is people should be able to do
whatever they want in the comfort of
their home
consensually and legally so long as
they're not abridging or infringing on
the rights of anybody else right but
then I thought to myself but when you
use the word legal well there have been
horrible policies that have been legal
in the past and because it was legal
people use that as an excuse to continue
on with it you know should we introduce
what is moral what is ethical and I
think that's the conversation to be had
as well because some of the things that
are happening in America uh like the
Patriot Act for example uh just because
it's legal does that make it right yeah
a lot of the back to blue people need to
also realize you know a lot of the worst
atrocities in recorded human history
were illegal and when they say I'm just
following the law I'm just I'm just
doing what I'm told they're going along
with some of the worst actions that have
happened to human beings whether it's
slavery the genocide the Holocaust you
name it all of that was codified by law
so so we need to really start seeing
things from a different perspective a
lot more people are becoming Godless uh
I I think that also is maybe having an
effect on this I I never believe the
government will be there to solve any of
your problems I think they're only there
to create more problems in your life so
how do you enforce that in a way without
using government is is a question that I
think a lot of people should be asking
themselves what is there is there a
solution without you know big Force big
government doing this for us usually
social ostracization like if you can get
people ground up to believe in a
morality but they control the culture
and they and they're pushing people to
not be religious they're pushing people
not to believe in a higher power above
themselves this is why the left calls
people white supremacists I want you to
think about that story uh Gore melts you
guys heard the gore melt story out of
Fredericksburg VA there's a uh during
covid lockdown the guy who owns it says
I'm not doing this you can't shut me
down that's unconstitutional Bravo good
sir Matt Strickland and
uh eventually they say okay then we're
gonna we're gonna shut you down we're
gonna take your license from you so he's
in this dispute it's two years later
basically and they go into his business
the police to serve a search warrant and
give them a suspension or whatever and
try and shut them down
what do you what how do you how do you
deal with cops like that well the left
figured it out you call them white
supremacists why it's one of the most
repugnant things you can call someone
it's also inactionable if you call
someone a white supremacist you cannot
they cannot sue you because it's an
opinion and what does it really even
mean the the the term is is nebulous
perhaps on purpose but for the average
voter they know what it means it means
something
so if you have cops coming to your
business they do this to you well my
idea was shun those cops right make sure
those cops can't buy a cup of coffee in
that town and if they ever want to eat
food again they'll have to move because
they've violated the rights of a good
hard-working businessman who is just
trying to keep he's trying to feed his
family keep his business operating serve
the community and the cops wanted to
violate the constitution so The Simple
Solution non-violent civil disobedience
is if you got a business in
Fredericksburg watch the video of those
cops and then put up signs in your
window saying you are not welcome here
turn around here's the issue how do you
make sure in a large city like that that
you you can stop people from supporting
those cops well if you go around and try
and explain the nuances of why they
violated the Constitution how they
violated the Constitution and why
someone should support your efforts to
Bar those cops they're going to say look
I have no time for this I have no idea
what you're talking about I don't know
what that means and then you go
they're white supremacists the guy's
gonna go oh okay they're not welcome
here then that simple that's why the
left does what they do they don't want
to waste time explaining anything to
anybody it's too long it's too
complicated no one cares they simply say
this guy is a Nazi and if you support
them you know what happens and they go
okay you got it the appeal to emotions
trying to emotionally get someone to be
afraid of serving them emotionally
that's that's why they do it because
it's the fastest and easy way to get
someone barred from from a business get
their bank account shut down get them
banned from social media
it is a functional tactic
my knee-jerk reaction is I I you know
again I haven't thought this through but
I don't think maybe we should be using
the same kind of policies that they used
and I think there is some kind of
government we should keep serving these
cops and let them eat a burgers at our
restaurant I'm not saying that I'm
specifically uh going about using this
kind of mass generalization and again I
haven't thought this through just call
them just call it yeah I said that's why
the left does it I know we do it we have
to shun them from our businesses but the
reason they use these terms is because
it's very difficult to explain in
complicated politics I always actually
considered using the tactic because like
you were saying earlier we use the
tactics they use if there's ever like a
competition of something if you don't
you're going to get snowballed so like
you you kind of have to use the same but
then when they start using evil
underhanded tactics you're like the ends
don't justify the means in every system
situation I got it do you guys know
where the word uh rape comes from like
the the root of it what it means no
so obviously in modern society it means
you know typically a man forcing himself
on a woman though in modern times it is
used woman on men as well but there's a
reason why the phrase raping and
pillaging is together because it used to
refer specifically to Barbara swords
going into a village
destroying it and stealing everything so
that was raping The Village was to take
all their stuff but in the process like
the Vikings for instance they would take
women with them and that's how it went
to to get this specific meaning in
today's day and age but uh if if
semantics is all we're really talking
about then those cops rape that guy
right and then you can say there here's
here's a copy he's a rapist
well that's what rape means right the
traditional definition if you want to
play Fight Fire with Fire and play those
games that's the that that's the game
they play
now here's here's my issue I agree right
I don't like those tactics I don't want
to live in that world I don't want to
live in a world where people are just
saying things to mean something they
don't really mean because they're trying
to trick people
but how do you and I mean sincerely I'm
not saying we should utilize those the
tactics of manipulation I'm saying how
what what is the counter
to those manipulative tactics in a way
that we can stop bad cops from like
raiding businesses like this
I mean I I'm kind of guilty I just did
it today I posted on my Instagram you
know some tweets of mine uh criticizing
uh Joe Biden freeing The Merchant of
death to Russia and I said on my
Instagram account Joe Biden is a Russian
asset I I don't believe that's trying to
trick or manipulate uh I think it's true
with the Nordstrom 2 and uh and with his
policy of trading terrorists for
Americans because it's going to set
precedent but I think it's a duality yes
we need to do those tactics as
truthfully as we can because look at the
end of the day we live in a world where
information travels so quickly that
people just want to be the first at
everything and it doesn't matter whether
it's true or false they just want to be
the first because it means that
information is going to travel as
quickly as possible globally but I think
Ian and I uh well hopefully everybody at
this table would agree that 99.9 percent
of of people around the globe are good
decent human beings but it's the 0.1
percent that is the loudest minority
which seems to be in control because
they're able to say those terrible
things about others and so many are
unwilling or maybe unable to speak uh
against them and I think that we need to
lead by example yes speak out but also
lead by example with conservative policy
with passing conservative legislation
and showing people uh
an alternative an alternative to what
the Democrats have been using against us
and let's show how we can do it in a
righteous and virtuous way and to give
you an example look at uh look at
Baltimore everybody was having this
conversation about trash in the city but
nobody was doing anything and so I said
okay I'm gonna go pick up trash and it
was that one action which spurred others
to go wait a second I can do the same
thing why are we going to wait for the
government
to come in and save us we can do it
ourselves and that that one action of
mine empowered so many people to believe
that they could do the same and I think
that truly is part of the answer lead by
example
so to answer I guess that and what
you're saying like a boycotting these
cops which I'm not necessarily agreeing
with but it is a way to deal with the
situation of people of cops over
overarching their Authority like just
one restaurant manager at a time one guy
tells one guy Word of Mouth rather than
trying to lie about these guys and to
fame them just be straight up they came
in they they shut they shut down an
aspect of my business against if it
actually violates the Constitution or
you know we could just take photos of
them and put up wanted posters saying
that there's Pirates going around town
destroying people's livelihoods and
business and that technically is not a
lie too right it would say not wanted
because they don't want them no no no no
or beware pictures of Beware uh Pirates
running around shutting down businesses
on beheads of uh bureaucrats yeah as
long as hey these guys will do whatever
it takes uh to screw you over if they
have to you know I think even those
beware posters might be something maybe
I should just pick a bunch of billboards
all over Fredericksburg with their
pictures on it that could be yeah that
could be well you can do that that's
free speech so uh if I put up a bun if I
put their photos from the video on
billboards and then put do not serve
these men in your establishment they're
bad cops that's my free speech it's not
actionable and I and Billboard's cost
between a couple hundred and a couple
thousand dollars depending on where
they're why don't we just set a budget
and put those those Billboards up all
over Fredericksburg Virginia yeah I'll
make a phone call first thing in the
morning that's absolutely one way of
doing it uh doing Flyers passing out
flyers being like hey you know this is a
community effort here I I think also a
meeting with the community meeting with
uh the restaurant owner and the the
other businesses and other people of
that community and seeing how they want
to handle this too uh creating a
relationship with them and and having
them come together when something bad
happens I think is also something that
could be incredibly strong and
Incredibly powerful of people saying hey
we live together we're in the same
Community together there was clearly a
state that committed a crime and a
violation against a private Enterprise
and a private business here that was
serving the community let let's come
together and let's act together and you
might not even have to buy a billboard
it could be posters it could be uh you
know just a piece of paper with the
photos photocopied put up everywhere on
on polls yeah with diplomacy you could
get together with the restaurant owner
the police chief and then maybe have a
conversation publicly where they realize
we are going to reinstate the liquor
license that was a bad move and we're
not going to do it again that would be
better than just smashing at people that
made you angry and then they're gone and
now new people are going to keep making
the same issue over and over again you
got to go after those guys and like well
no no no no no I think I think I want to
put the Billboards up and I'll just put
beware dirty cops and I'll put their
pictures up on the billboard warning
they would have to you know think twice
if they're going to do something like
that it's true historically cops would
not mess with people in their own
environment they'd have to bring police
in from another state or from like the
government from like a state government
because local cops don't mess with their
friends and family like those are your
neighbors and for good reason and that
kept things in order when you know the
cop had to come down and deal with a
brawl it's like listen we got to stop
the fight break it up guys look your
dad's gonna be pissed I don't want to
deal with this now they bring in cops
from Two Towns over and they walk in and
say don't know don't care pull the taser
just jabbed the guy in this instance
it's a guy who was standing up for his
constitutional rights and two years
later they're like we're going to
destroy your business okay those are
dirty cops I'm sorry that that is
they're like don't know don't care well
you probably have to so you know someone
super chatted what about The Thin Blue
Line and protecting us from chaos yeah
if like in New York a dude steals a
school bus and is ramming people then
like I got no issue with the cops like
that's that's I agree like there's a
reason why we have police officers for
such equations of like a guy running
around with a gun but we're talking
about a dude who is who's operating a
business that sold beer and the only
reason they went after his liquor
license was because he said Fu to their
unconstitutional edict
the cops want to enforce that okay
they're dirty they're dirty cops and uh
you know maybe maybe I'll just put up
Billboards dirty cops and I'll and I'll
and I'll put them all over the place
they protected Walmart they protected
Costco they allowed all the businesses
with connections to politicians to stay
open McDonald's you could walk in there
get whatever you wanted no problem but
but this guy who had a small business
had to be shut down by these politicians
now years after the these edicts because
a politician went to police officers and
said go enforce this and the police
officer said yes sir I'll do it right
away and and all these back to Blue guys
need to face the reality because the
National Security State is being turned
around on the people of America it used
to be that they were fighting you know
terrorists but that again don't even get
me started on all that but but you know
you do a lot of positive activism that
you just mentioned in Baltimore is there
a way to turn this situation and do some
kind of positive activism here with this
well I wasn't even thinking that way
well I agree that we need to keep it to
the individual and you know make it
known that we're we're not painting with
a broad brush and yes we do support the
police but we don't support the police
when they are choosing as individuals to
enforce unconstitutional legal mandates
but groups like black lives matter and I
want to make it very clear I don't
support black lives matter but if they
were smart they're working all of these
conversations seem limited to short-term
goals if I were a part of black lives
matter and I really wanted to make a
difference I'd say join the police force
become a policeman because then you are
going to be the enforcer of the laws
that you are for or against right and
same for us as conservatives when we're
calling out uh the sexualization of
children within our schools well a
long-term approach will be become a
school board member become a city
council member and become a teacher
become the solution to the problem
you're talking about in the law long
term that would be more my positive
activism as to actually try to solve
this from a long-term perspective yeah
let's let's jump to this uh story about
uh Joe Biden this is from The Daily Mail
quote I don't understand why I'm sitting
I'm still sitting here my bags are
packed devastated Paul Whalen breaks his
silence from Russian penal colony as his
brother slams his catastrophic exclusion
from Brittany Greiner prison swap I'm
ready to go home let me show you the
truth
Jordan shackel says NBC News announced
State propaganda Outlet is participating
in the cover-up operation first edition
versus stealth edited in the original
archive it says
but the official said Russia has treated
well indifferently because he is an
accused spy and that the Kremlin gave
the White House the choice of either
Griner or wellin or none they edit it to
say
they gave the White House the choice of
either Griner or no one after different
options were proposed
because the reality is Joe Biden had a
choice
this former U.S marine
or a WNBA star you know the WNBA Star
hates America as much as he does and is
part of the cult so this is what Joe
Biden chooses to do your values as an
American who believes in people
sacrificing for the greater good are not
held by these people and these are the
people that have near just just absolute
raw power in this country through ballot
harvesting or otherwise they control the
institutions and they are the I view I
view these people as a parasitic cult
that is suckling the blood from this
country and and gutting it ripping it to
shreds there's another aspect to this uh
prisoner swap deal that a lot of people
are missing and that was the involvement
of the Saudi Empire Saudi Arabia that by
the way the United States just declared
immune for the cash Hoagie killing they
literally cited Biden's administration's
executive powers and and and stopped any
further investigations and legal
responsibility for the killing of cash
Hoagie uh with Saudi Arabia Saudi Arabia
country that negotiated this larger
prisoner swap with many people now
speculating that this was a part of the
deal of the United States getting uh
Brittany grinder back to the United
States and and it absolutely does make
sense because as we know Biden was
trying to do this before the midterm
elections in order to try to get
political uh favors in order to look uh
good to his base he wasn't able to
achieve that this Saudi Arabian
development does make sense now and it
wasn't just this former U.S vet that was
screwed over here but it was also the
family of kashoggi who also was
connected to intelligence agencies as
well that was screwed over here as well
so
it's like oh I mean Biden it's kind of a
smart move in my point in my opinion
over Weyland it's I dislike it but you
saw Micah Parsons on Twitter get
absolutely roasted for saying why is
Griner coming home and he's an athlete
famous athlete why is grinder coming
home and we have a a veteran overseas
and he got blasted by the the mob the
Twitter mob so Biden knows who's paying
attention to him you know
I just I just don't view view the the
leftists like the way I described it
several months ago was I don't care what
they think it's like asking me what the
people of France think about my opinions
like well we're not France you know I
don't view them and and this is not a
thing where
I'm trying to say this because I I'm mad
at this group of people or I don't like
them I genuinely don't think since the
pandemic when Biden came out and said
we're gonna lock down and I'm like but
red States aren't locking down I went oh
man we're two different countries that's
just it the left and right both agree we
are two different countries but a lot of
people on the right don't seem to get it
they keep saying our democracy and
people are like we don't live in a
democracy it's a constitution no bro
they're saying they have a democracy you
aren't a part of
so we got to do something but it's not a
democracy they say it's a democracy but
it's an oligarchy they're running it at
the top behind the scenes it's
administrators and yeah politicians and
bankers Deuteronomy that's a good word
bureaucracy and I don't think
bureaucracy really gets to the element
of the economic function of a thought so
I say beeronomy because it's like
bureaucracy just implies there's like a
system of paperwork and you know
bureaucrats running things but it's also
the the system of cell the system itself
of who gets access to resources is you
know the economic functions functions of
it it's not just oligarchy it's uh I
guess you can just call it classical
communism right like Chinese Chinese
Communist style that's what it is I
think they're losing you know so I'm
chill the the exposure that we're
getting out of the Twitter file stuff
that seeing what they're doing behind
the scenes and what the FBI has been
doing I'm like oh okay you know
they're going to lose they can't
maintain this but I think what what
helps is people realizing that uh
they're
you don't share a system with them
well I'm not sure with this story that
we need to really be focusing on on
Brittany and I just thought it was so
and what I mean by that is you know the
press secretary today was saying this is
a victory for the gay community and
black women everywhere and I'm like what
what does that have to do with anything
the fact of the matter is we traded a
terrorist an arms dealer that conspired
to kill Americans that is responsible
for deaths across the globe
to our enemy our adversary and I just I
I have to point this out I just uh it's
a terrible precedent and president quite
frankly that was set under President
Obama because I was looking at Bergdahl
and uh correct me if I'm wrong but
President Obama traded five Guantanamo
Bay uh individuals that were a part of
the Taliban for that for that one uh
American who apparently uh according to
sources had betrayed and run off and
then during President Trump we had
Americans that were freed from North
Korea we had the students that were
freed from China and we had Ayah hijazi
and her husband that were freed from
Egypt three different situations and
North Korea who could be more hostile
yeah I I think that is analogous to
Russia or China and president Trump
didn't have to trade an arms dealer or
terrorist in order to free those
American citizens and so that that needs
to be a part of the conversation has
nothing to do with identity gender Etc
it has to be at what point
do we concede in order to get something
back to America and furthermore I just
want to also make the point I think this
is not unexpected from the very
Administration that gave billions uh in
military equipment to the Taliban to
begin with so this is something that I
I'm not surprised or shocked yeah I was
going to say what what this guy is
accused of doing is what the U.S
intelligence deep state has been doing
for a number of years now so let's just
call spade a spade here it's a he's a
very fascinating guy because he started
selling machetes and single shot rifles
to Africa then moved on to AK-47s uh he
was charged with conspiracy to kill
Americans the d.a.a said a couple months
ago that his release would pose quote
grave national security threat to the
United States he's also alleged to have
tried to sell missiles to blow up U.S
passenger Airlines he is alleged to have
stolen 32 billion dollars of weapons
from Ukraine these are again all
allegations this is this is where the
movie by uh I forgot the title uh by um
what's his name that weird face looking
guy Quentin Tarantino no no sorry Quinn
I love you uh Nicholas Cage there's
Nicholas Cage movie oh yeah yeah yeah
that movie was good that movie was based
on this guy the oh really yes the in the
beginning of the movie is that where
that shows the bullet yep God of War God
of War yep I think that's no no hold on
Lord of War something like that someone
in the chat room will tell us but but
his life was uh you know depicted in
that particular movie by Nick and his
cage can I just you know the first thing
I thought of when I heard this like
Luke's mentioning this guy is like a
wanted terrorist he tried to kill
Americans he's selling missiles to us
enemies he's it's we've been warned that
he's a tremendous threat but we got
Brittany Greiner and the first thing I
think of is Dumb and Dumber when the
dude rides up on the little scooter on
the on the moped and then he's like what
happened he's like I traded the van for
it 70 miles to the gallon and he's like
just when I think you couldn't do you
couldn't be any stupider you go and do
something like this and totally redeem
yourself
trading your van for a a pit bike that's
what this feels like we had The Merchant
of death and Biden's like well we do
need a d-list celebrity back in the
country that's what the that's what the
you know corporate media is calling him
and it was Lord of War the movie if you
haven't watched it yet I thought I
thought it was a great movie I was very
entertained by it and it's based off
real life Events off of this particular
guy now the other side of the story is
that a lot of this has trumped up
charges that this was personally
directed as a major political hit job
against Putin because he was pretty much
working within the Russian uh
intelligencia deep State selling weapons
where the Russian government couldn't
officially sell weapons too so again the
United States does this as well his main
crime was again financing Al Qaeda and
Isis and that's literally what the
United States did as well so your tax
dollars went to doing that this guy did
it as well and he was held and he was he
was held in uh captive in 2010 and was
supposed to send it was supposed to
serve for 25-year sentence I got I I got
standards right yeah principles Brittany
Greiner should not be getting charged
and locked up like she was in in Russia
and all that stuff Americans for weed
right yeah it was uh a THC uh uh Vapor
or something and so so you know look I
think it's silly but she did break
Russian law I just don't you know and
you gotta abide by the rules but we can
we can do some kind of trade I got no
problem with that I think Brittany
Greiner should be back home United
States
um I'm just sitting here being like when
it comes to swapping the Lord of War
Merchant of death can't we do a little
better this has got to be like the worst
Biden needs to read the art of the deal
yes like because he has no idea how to
negotiate this stuff he just just traded
I'm saying a van for a pit bike yeah and
when you look at the way that uh Donald
Trump handled negotiations especially
when it came to prisoner swaps he did a
way better job especially when it came
to the situation in Turkey I believe
there was a pastor that was being held
there Donald Trump wanted him back in
the United States and then he started to
tweet about how the Lira was a crap
currency the currency started to go down
and turkey was demanding very uh tough
requests from the United States and then
ended up not giving up anything
according to the official story and the
way he handled that was I think a lot
better and again I'm critical of Donald
Trump you guys know that obviously in
the chat room I see it every single day
but I think the way he handled that was
a lot better than what Biden just did
now Biden's looking for a flash in the
pan he constantly looks for these like
little shocks bright light flashes to
keep people interested that's what it
seems like this is a publicity stunt
really more than anything for him I
think although I'm glad Britney's back
you know well let's be honest she was a
political prisoner right she was held up
there cap actively sentenced for eight
years in a very tough rush in jail I I
wouldn't want you to be in her situation
she was there because uh she was playing
basketball she was getting paid to play
basketball there and
um you know to me no one should be
charged for eight years for a substance
that they wanted to personally use
themselves to me that idea is just
absolutely insane so clearly the Russian
government was holding her as a
political pawn and clearly that
political Pawn played off and has been
incentivized by this larger trade deal
which at the end of the day only
incentivizes Russia to do this again to
other American citizens that are in
Russia if you really do think about this
I want to lighten things up a little bit
you know we're dealing with some dark
subjects and we got a really dark
subject in in a bit but let's let's uh
let's let's start with something that's
going to give everybody a good laugh
Here We Go From The Guardian Twitter
sued for disproportionately firing
female workers after musk buyout the
proposed class action lawsuit alleges
that after the Takeover 57 of women were
laid off compared with 47 percent of men
the reason why I say that's funny is
because there's that Meme where Elon
Musk he did this he sent an email saying
will you make the pledge to work hard
yes or no if no I you will be laid off
and get three months Severance and then
this data comes out where there are like
57 of the people who get laid up for
women so at first I understand Elon Musk
did laugh a bunch of people immediately
without question but then he came back
with that who wants to work hard and who
doesn't so you've got a few things here
is it that ten percent uh proportionally
more women were like I would not want to
work hard there's an article from The
Washington Post that says Elon musk's
vision of working late hours at the cost
of sleep family and friends is
retrograde and it was like it's like
written by a woman and I'm just kind of
like
you know the sound the idea of working
16 hours a day at the cost of all those
things is appealing to me is there is
there something where there's like a
difference between men and women on this
one we know that uh women tend to be
subject-oriented men tend to tend to be
object oriented is that the cause of
this or is there just a simple there
were more women working in comms and
more calms people got fired there were
more men working in engineering so less
of them got fired or something like that
it's that Meme you know what I mean
where uh before Twitter it's all women
and then after it's all men
or you guys think Elon sexist
what do you think
I I don't have a funny answer to it but
I would probably just say that 57 or a
good percentage maybe cared about that
they had that uh disamplification or
disenhancement you know they were taking
away visibility from people that did
they didn't agree with and they simply
were just saying okay if elon's gonna
take over and if he's not going to
censor these beliefs that we don't agree
with I don't want to work for that
company and and it's not that big of a
margin what is it 57 I mean how do you
quantify that especially when it's you
know a few hundred people what was that
a few thousand people well I mean here's
the issue too there were more men
working for the company than women so
this means more men got fired than women
but when you compare only men to men and
women to women then the percentages make
it seem like more women got fired yeah
this feels like it's just a frivolous
lawsuit meant to entangle Elon Musk and
to stop him from doing other things and
to drain away his resources uh that's
just my initial reaction to this I could
be wrong but I highly doubt a lot lot of
the decisions were based off sexist
Decisions by Elon Musk to me there's no
evidence showing that at all and it's a
ridiculous claim in my opinion yeah I
find um I don't know there's a tendency
for men to be more obsessed with Science
Tech and things and women to be more
obsessed with people and like things
like that especially when it comes to
coding especially when it comes to
development sitting in a building for 16
hours without a shower and stinking is
I'm okay with it I do that almost every
day in fact I like it
um but most women I know like to be
clean especially because they need to be
clean for health reasons cleaner than
men well it's not just that but but
predominantly men like to of course be
Engineers like to build and develop
women like to organize women like to
keep things orderly not always but but
more generally speaking that's the case
here and when we look at the jobs at
Twitter they're going to be not doing
what they did before they're going to be
developing essentially what is the next
WeChat here in the United States and
encompassing everyday life which is
going to include a lot of coding a lot
of hard engineering work in order to
develop the app of everything the X app
as Elon Musk has called it so that's not
going to attract a lot of people who
aren't going to be able to tell people
what to say and what to think and to
Shadow them because they can't do that
anymore I think there's a lot of
administrative bloat at Twitter a bunch
of middle management and maybe they were
more women in middle management maybe
there were more guys I mean we saw the
videos they're like oh yeah we got free
wine
if you ever stopped that right now and
then and then obviously retrograde I
want wine and Legos yeah I guess it
depends on what you want to do with your
tech company but I find like you want
about 90 of your employees to be
programmers I don't know maybe that's a
little off base I have only run one tech
company I didn't really run it myself I
helped run it but remember what was it
poly pocket you remember that thing yeah
what was the dude version maximum Mighty
Max Mighty Max was that what it was I
was all about it yeah and it was like
you had a little thing you'd open it and
get a little game and then the girl
version was the Polly Pocket you know
maybe I'll throw I'll throw a bone to
the left people Millennials were
socialized very very differently young
women play with different toys than
young boys and that leads them to be
very different when they're older that's
going to have an impact on how people
want to work in their jobs the way
they're raised that that I will say
outright so at the very least that could
be the case I'll also say one of the
tricks that they that the left uses is
they turn the out the the obvious and
overt differences between men and women
into racism misogyny discrimination Etc
or I should say in this instance
misogyny returned to sexism if uh women
need more sick days than men for you
know health reasons you will then see if
you look at I I'd be willing I I'd be
willing to bet but I could be wrong I'm
interested to see it do women take off
more sick leave than men
what do you guys think more time I would
imagine just if if raising families is
involved but that's not super common no
no sick leave just take days getting
sick and having a hard time working you
think men or women more likely to I
don't know for sure but my my personal
view is like I bet women would because
women have health issues and I got no
issue with that but imagine if I then
went into the directory and said for
some reason all of these women are
abusing the Health Care System certainly
it's what's going on right men and women
are are different the the genders are
bimodal it means there's two big bell
curves they overlap greatly but there
are some differences if this means that
women overwhelmingly work in comms and
Men overwhelmingly work in engineering
than when the layoffs come and they say
we're laying off Communications and it
disproportionately affects women they
then ignore that fact of the differences
between men and women and say ah the
fact that he find where women proves
that he's a sexist and it's in its
illegal discrimination but in reality
you don't need a huge bloated comms unit
in a tech company I don't think so they
are obviously I guess when you get to
the level that Twitter's at you become a
bit more of a Communications Department
than you are when you're a startup Tech
platform because the government wants to
come talk to people and have you have
Departments of people they're doing
Communications and stuff so maybe I can
see that changing but you know for the
benefit of the good of the the future of
the work I don't think you need massive
comms you know I was right according to
the Department of Labor women take
around 32 days I think uh is per year
and men take 25. huh they got ovaries
yeah well quite frankly
from the very people that have been
censoring us and there was no rationale
behind it there was no policy that
actually
you know said said that's what we were
doing I have trouble believing the very
people that were lying about the reasons
why we were censored in the first place
that they are being discriminated
against to begin with and quite frankly
I mean I don't I don't think I have
sympathy for them you know it's kind of
like when CNN is laying off people
certainly I don't want anybody to be out
of a job and not be able to provide for
their family but it's like if you've
been maligning us and doing horrible
things to us that I'm not sure I have
sympathy for you when you are losing
your job I got more data
in terms of General leave just not even
sick women take uh what is it 34 days
versus men's 21 days that's interesting
twice as much and it says primarily they
take longer leaves for a new child women
take 54 days versus men taking 18. but I
totally get it like I don't I don't
expect a guy to take 54 days he didn't
birth this child you know I think women
would just I think women deserve that
time off I think men should get a good
amount of time off to be with their kids
don't get me wrong but I mean that's
just biological differences it's going
to manifest in various ways they want
more time off what if Elon went in and
said fire anybody who took more than 30
days off this year he didn't say
anything about women but that would get
rid of more women than men right are
these uh full-time employees that I see
down here at the bottom it says uh 3700
are these full-time employees are these
people they're working one day a week
I'd be curious to see the those numbers
I don't know if they have them but I
think a lot of people were considered
full-time but were remoting in and we're
like you know just doing bare minimum
and that's part of elon's issue with it
it blows my mind to think that if the
owner of a company comes in is like
someone's doing a patch up like you're
doing a bad job I've given you some
warnings you're fired and they're like
you're firing me because I'm white I'm
like no I'm firing you because you suck
get out no it's because I'm tall you're
firing me because I'm a woman because
I'm black like dude you suck at your job
get out end a story why do you get to
pick social politics and bring that into
it I don't get it I don't get it well
the woke people live in this world where
everything is based on race or identity
instead of looking at
you know instead of looking at the data
and being like hmm I wonder I wonder why
more women take time off nope nope it's
it's discrimination you know I bet there
are situations where it's not a cop-out
so I shouldn't speak all for all time
but there are many many times when I
think the best the worst people will get
fired and it has nothing to do with your
identity it's purely because of your
ability
or or because you just your position
isn't needed anymore you know you got to
be so good that the company needs you
you got to make your position so
valuable that the company can't run
without it I mean that's one way to do
it the left wants companies to keep on
bad employees because of the employee's
identity
that just that just doesn't work it's
good on paper yeah well you know and
then you get bridges that collapse and
stuff like that you should see the laws
that they have in California when it
comes to boards and uh their regulations
there which is again absolutely insane
but I you know there's a lot of data
suggesting that you know men do work
more days in a year on average than
women do does this have an effect here
maybe I think so I think this cycle has
happened a lot in history and what I
don't want to happen is for it to become
where people resent let's pick women for
instance or some sort of class of human
a female white black you know whatever
that people because the job the
companies start to suffer because
they're forced to have a certain amount
of women and a certain amount of men and
maybe it doesn't matter their
qualifications that people will start to
resent those people those under
qualified people that got the position
on identity and then if the system
really falls apart there's going to be
massive amounts of resentment and then
you'll start over with this really like
stream system where people are like
women aren't the women people have
actually joked about repealing the 19th
Amendment because they're so frustrated
with this stuff wait wait what do you
mean joked yeah exactly it's not if some
people haven't even joked they just say
it's maybe we should strip women's right
to vote because they're so pissed off
when we're being forced into positions
they're not qualified for for identity
purposes what what is a woman Ian
good question Tim good question so I
tweeted that um now that we know that
biological sex isn't real we should
repeal the 19th Amendment because it's
become redundant
right I'm telling you well why would you
need it if biological sex isn't real the
19th Amendment specifically says the
right to vote shall not be uh in you
know Abridged or whatever or whatever
the word is uh so you can't it says sex
specifically says sex that the right to
vote will not be stopped because of your
sex but if the left's position is that
biological sex doesn't exist anymore
well then we don't need the 19th
Amendment everybody agrees no seriously
if they if if so that's the first
question I have you go to you go to
conservatives like you know Milo or
whatever he says outright you know
repeal the 19th Lydia she says repeal
the 19th and it's like okay well you
know like I personally don't agree with
that but I'm also not somebody who
thinks biological sex uh doesn't exist I
think it does so then fine here's my
pitch to Milo and to Lydia go to
leftists and say is biological sex a
real thing when they say no be like okay
would you like sign this position to
repeal the 19th Amendment which
specifically grants voting rights based
on sex that's that's transphobic isn't
it okay great then when they sign it
there you go get your petitions get your
your your two-thirds of States Article
Five convention or whatever and then you
can repeal the 19th but the reality is
men and women are different they have
women have ovaries genetically sexually
or different Creations you know maybe
gender is a conversation is worth having
that people have different you know
gender identities whatever but
biological sex is very real it's very
real we're all born of a woman as far as
I know all of us here probably were you
guys I was I had a mom and a dad sperm
in an egg female and a male they work
together you sound like a bigot how dare
you express these opinions I mean I have
to disavow immediately
um Scott do you disavow Ian
absolutely thank you not yes
uh okay good I think a lot of times
personalities get labeled as gender
identities too and it's just like people
are different men and women are
different people are different we all
come from different backgrounds
different cultures and there's too often
people are trying to put you in a little
box say this is what you are and it's
just like yo be an individual you know
dude that's awesome thinking of it as a
personality trait difference instead of
a gender differ it doesn't have to be
gender just because your personality
feels like something
yeah that's a good point well it's just
so ironic you know because they're
they're looking for these immutable
characteristics as diversity but they
won't include diversity of thought of
ideology of religion that's too much
that's too much we got to keep it
superficial here you know so they they
took the video down it was it was a
debate between Jordan Peterson and this
professor the video is now unavailable
but the quote was
basically it's not correct that there is
such a thing as biological sex uh he
said I'm a historian of medicine I can
break that down in great detail but for
the purpose in the sake of time I won't
and uh it was a Jordan Peterson having a
debate on gender so and this is 2016. if
that's the position they want to take I
mean man that's six years ago six years
ago this is a long time that means a 12
year old who was not paying attention to
politics back then is voting now that's
crazy and they don't think that
biological sex exists all right well
then the 19th Amendment doesn't need to
exist either
I think it's okay that biological sex
exists it's so weird when people
conflate sex and gender too I don't like
that the sex thing is just like
blatantly real sex is real like male and
men and women are both here together I
gotta say though I I don't see how they
argue themselves away from that one the
19th Amendment explicitly says on the
basis of sex if they don't think it
exists then what is the basis for the
19th Amendment
simply put ask them ask your Lefty
friends calmly and do you think we
should have a 19th Amendment yeah the
one that you know what that does it
affirms in the Constitution that
biological sex is real that that's
transphobic right well then we gotta get
rid of it
it doesn't necessarily affirm because
there could be zero women
and the 19th Amendment could still be
there just wouldn't be affecting anyone
so what they see that could be a
situation where they're like hey there
are no Sexes so let's repeal the
redundancy and then all of a sudden
they're like actually there are Sexes
you guys are gonna have to work to get
an Amendment of the Constitution to get
to vote again like no no no no
everyone's able to vote now that's hey
look if they want to remove their own
right to vote then people can vote away
their right to vote I guess
it's their view not mine hey let's move
on to the next story yes you guys ready
to go in some dark territory yeah man do
you guys see that commercial that was
glorifying euthanasia where the woman
was like I can choose to die and then
like they're all dancing around or
whatever
she didn't want to die
she wanted to live but they wouldn't
give her the care she needed so she
could live so she opted to die instead
because the state is California I'm
sorry this is Canada I don't mean like
the United States I mean like the
government state said well we can't give
you the adequate Health Care you need
but we can't kill you and she said fine
from the National Post woman featured in
pro-euthanasia commercial wanted to live
say friends quote I feel like I'm
falling through the crack so if I'm not
able to access health care am I then
able to access death care hatch said in
a CTV interview
so when they did the commercial showing
this woman about how she wanted to die
because she had a connective tissue
disorder what they omitted from that was
that she had given interviews and that
her friends had pleaded to give her the
care she needed because she didn't want
to die
now in Canada they're currently having a
debate over whether or not to extend
euthanasia to children so uh
you know this morning when I see the
project Veritas stuff I'm like oh I'm
gonna put on some 90s commercials I'm
going to do it tomorrow too just zone
out and be like ah yeah cheeseburgers
for 50 cents what do you guys think
about assisted suicide what about you
what do you think Scott well in regards
to the story I just think it's
disgusting that
it's cheaper to kill someone to than to
keep them alive and I think that's what
it comes down to money
and uh you know we've seen that from
everything from Pharmaceuticals you know
the trying to get rid of competition
because if it means that there's a
cheaper solution to keep somebody alive
affects somebody's pocketbooks they're
willing to try to destroy that
competition which is going to make
people pay more in order to to stay
alive I just think it's all together
disgusting it's like the government has
an invested interest in in killing
people and depopulating them and making
sure that they no longer exist it's like
almost everything they do and they
incentivize goes down this one very dark
path uh the The Daily Caller has a very
interesting article that's headlined
euthanasia is now a leading cause of
death in Canada yeah three three percent
three percent of all deaths in Canada
were people being killed by the state
you know at what point is it genocide
so that's a good question
well it's a question that I think a lot
of people should be asking themselves
the world is just upside down you know I
I recently had a health scare
very ill went to the hospital and
because I've been Frugal because I've
saved every cent because
um I'm with Mom and Dad I'm in a 2005
Honda Civic I'm not living the lap of
luxury and because that I haven't spent
every cent I'm actually being penalized
for that where if my bank account said
zero dollars than I would be getting
better health care than being a
responsible physical Citizen and it just
uh every aspect of our society we seem
to reward irresponsibility and we reward
uh not having accountability and
transparency
unemployment is exactly that they'll say
don't get a job or you'll lose your your
free money so don't get a job as soon as
you get a job you lose your unemployment
check so there's no incentive yeah and
then you're you're watching and you're
saying oh I can't make this much money
because then I won't receive government
assistance and there's no incentive to
better your life why should I I'm going
to be taken care of
it they used tribal life used to be much
more hard I would I mean they would if
you couldn't walk you're there they
leave you on the ground as they all have
to travel on to find food somewhere else
you can't keep up sorry grandpa or
whatever maybe they throw in the back of
a wagon but if you're just gonna eat
lettuce and just waste our the tribe's
food and not contribute at some point
like harsh reality takes over but now
we're in a society where like people are
severely obese severely uh unhealthy
depressed not even contributing to
society because they're so depressed and
they're still like trying to support
those people and have those people breed
and like make more of that it feels like
no they're doing the opposite of that
they're trying to make sure that they
don't breed that they don't have
families that they don't reproduce that
they get eliminated but people get money
for having more kids more Social
Security and stuff or more um government
tax benefits it depends on what
jurisdiction you're in depends on what
state you're in and it's just enough to
keep you floating but but never enough
to prosper just to keep you dependent on
on the government but I mean that's what
they what they want a Ubi and in some
senses in some jurisdictions they
already have that but what they're doing
in Canada seems absolutely Draconian
seems absolutely I would even go as far
as to say evil uh there's a new bill C7
that wants to allow miners to be able to
be euthanized by state Doctors Without
The consent of their parents that's
literally the laws that they're trying
to pass there and they're they're ruling
that mentally ill minors are legally
allowed to uh be you know euthanized
against the will of their parents so
um especially with mental health being
so just I want you guys
you know we've seen this stuff with
Florida with the parental rights and
education
imagine it's either you or someone you
know or just a third party
kid doesn't come home from school
parents get worried
14 year old teenage girl or something
so they call the police they called the
school the school says uh we don't we
don't have anything to tell you we're
sorry we say what what's going on well
we don't know they call the police the
police are like okay we'll look into it
the next day I was someone from the
school from the administration with the
police show up knock on the door and say
we didn't want to tell you this
yesterday because it's none of your
business but yesterday your child opted
for medical assistance and dying and we
assisted your child in going to the
doctor receiving a device which killed
them which assisted them in their own
death
you can go claim the body
I mean talk I know you've said like the
the violence of like watching kids get
sterilized against their parents will
watching a kid get killed against their
parents like without their parents I
mean that's complete topsy-turvy insane
if you look I know this is Canada but
with the Veritas stuff we saw last night
was probably it was probably one of the
most shocking things I have ever heard
it's bad enough we see these books like
we got genderqueer sent to the table Ian
bought it and you look at the images in
this and you're like Amazon says this
book is for adults only but they're
giving it to grade school kids and
putting it in their Library
then you hear from Veritas a guy
bragging about how he's got adult
objects for children with explanations
of how to spit on them to insert them
and things like that and as soon as I
heard that I said you can come to me
with any political Theory political
story but if you don't think that we're
headed towards some kind of civil
conflict then I would just say you're
wrong it's one thing when Joe Biden
weaponizes the doj sure it's overtly
political but when you hear a story like
what came out of veritas or when you
hear these stories about what's going on
in Canada they want to euthanize
children without alerting the parents
quite literally the state the government
of Canada is proposing they're debating
whether or not they can take your child
without telling you and kill them what's
the name of that bill again B Bill C7
kill your kid in a way the government
wants and Canada wants to kill your
child I'm open I know sorry just I know
Canada is not the United States but I'm
saying we are dangerously close to that
line where where people are just going
to say nope
I'm open to like assisted suicide I
always have kind of been like if someone
wants to kill themselves they're gonna
do it I mean Maybe not maybe not people
have been brought back from the edge but
if my buddy hung himself during covid
you know it wrecked me but whatever it's
still wrecking me right now
um if but no one could I don't think
anyone could have stopped him he wanted
he was he was finished and uh but the
kid to do it to a kid especially someone
on a pharmaceutical drug that's already
depressed do you know about the
documentary on the Golden Gate Bridge
we've talked about it before uh yeah
yeah every single person who survived
jumping off the Golden Gate Bridge said
as soon as they jumped they regretted
jumping and they realized that all of
their problems in life could have been
solved except having just jumped off the
Golden Gate Bridge
they were happy to be alive
most people who get past the depression
and suicide are happy to be alive it is
temporary it can be you can be saved the
government they said this in 2017 they
could save 140 million dollars by
killing people instead of treating them
this is the nightmare scenario of
government Health Care the system has to
be paid for somehow the system gets
strained people aren't getting there's
there's long lines there's complaints
people start protesting and they say
okay we need to figure out how to free
up the system I got it
we just kill people
that's what Canada is doing to save
money and treat people they will kill
those this is like
it's it's it's it's a governmental
Darwinism
well think about or Eugenics or democide
another way of you know saying it sorry
go ahead no just think about covid you
know we had doctors who were saying that
we shouldn't be treating patients who
are suffering from covid because they
didn't make the choice to get the
vaccine and you know similar to what we
saw with the censorship from Twitter I
think it's really no different who is in
control is going to be deciding who gets
benefited from the government and same
for what we were talking about earlier
with the Britney decision the Marine
wasn't chosen the American loving
freedom fighting Marine was discarded
over the gay black woman basketball
player because it was decided by the
government that that person was more
important than the other person and
that's exactly what we would see from
government decided Health Care you know
just think about a young person versus
an old person if they made the decision
why why would they choose to give the
kidney to the older person because they
would probably say oh they've got less
Life to Live they've got less value they
already did that here in the United
States when it came to deciding who's
going to get care based on their skin
color in Houston people were denied
life-saving treatment because they
weren't black because they were they
weren't in The Stereotype they weren't a
minority according to the group and they
were saying well too bad you're you're a
young male and you can't get this
treatment which is absolutely insane
this is why I'm going to open a hotel
that's going to have four floors and
each is a suite and each one is a is a
decade the 90s the 80s the 70s and the
60s and you'll go in like the 90s hotel
and everything's from the 90s you turn
the TV on it's good old 90s TV and you
can forget about all of the insanity
just plug into this this fake world the
windows will have TVs instead of windows
so yeah it's not real steak
no it is it will be real steak it tastes
real but it's not real pizza box from
the 90s from Pizza Hut and the Pizza Hut
guy shows up with a smile on his face 30
minutes or it's free and he hands you a
little booket thing for your kid I'm
making a matrix reference you know
Cipher was like why would you go back
into the real world when you can live in
The Matrix and taste this delicious
steak and and they're like because it's
not real in The Matrix you're just you
know but you know and then what we'll do
is we'll actually we'll build a big
complex unlike 50 acres and we'll create
a 90s City just so that like think about
it you know only landlines no cell
phones yeah yeah no no no I mean your
phone will work because you're there but
it'll be like a theme park and you'll go
in and everything's 90s it'll be like
walking into a 90s downtown there'll be
like a TV store there'll be cassette
tapes people riding bikes all over the
place Silver Diners everywhere Silver
Diners you know you see friends is on TV
and then it can just wash away all of
the troubles all of the troubles there's
no Ubers they're just bikes you have to
bike around everywhere get some exercise
the 90s I thought were really depressing
they were cool but it was like because
it was depressing people made the best
of it in the early 90s Kurt Cobain was
horribly depressed but but Ian just
imagine you're walking down the street
there's a guy and then you know he waves
to you and then all of a sudden he's
carrying he's carrying a boom box on his
shoulder and then you hear the radio DJ
say you know and now the the big hit
Inside Out by Eve six sweeping the
nation because people carry boom boxes
on their shoulders at least that's what
TV TV tells me and then you just you you
won't remember any of the troubles
outside of this this theme park in the
in the euthanasia and and all that stuff
okay I'm kidding but we gotta go to
super chats so if you haven't already
would you kindly smash that like button
subscribe to this channel share the
share with your friends become a member
at timcast.com we're gonna have a
members only show coming up for you
uncensored not censored uncensored but
let's read
j marie says Ian you're almost there
brother your desire to find the truth
will lead you in a proper direction my
latest is articulating the points you
have been saying lately it's three
minutes in called change the world j
marie thesis podcast dude I made a video
called change the world that was about
three minutes two in 2007 that proves it
or or you we are chain we are changing
the world it was something like that
it's on YouTube black oh yeah I think I
figured out I kept saying that if you
don't make me copyright you if you don't
believe in if you don't believe in God
you're not Jewish I was saying that a
couple like last week I'm starting to
wonder and I'm thinking about it I'm
doing some research on the history of
Israel and I think what happened is the
Judaism comes from Judah the son of
Jacob Jacob was known as Israel God
called him Israel after he wrestled with
an angel and so like they're really
Israeli like the culture is Israeli
comes from Jacob Jake tribe of Jacob and
then the the the the the problem is then
the belief in God and the understanding
all kind of infuses into the culture and
becomes like their constitution so it's
tough to I've I have a separation for
you talk to a rabbi yeah multiple rabbis
I'm so down and again Bryson gray last
night fantastic bringing back Hershey
oh yeah yeah
come on love to all right here we go
black lion grunt says Tim in your 90s
Hotel you must have a Nintendo 64 with
GoldenEye Mario Kart 64 Star Fox and
perfect dark and on one of the TV
channels the Fraser Saga of Dragon Ball
Z uh you know it I have uh uh I already
have an N64 with all those games but
someone sent me this website it's like
my90s tv.com was that was that what it
was yeah something like that let me see
if I still have it and I turned it on
and it was uh dragon warrior the anime
was on one of the channels and it's like
it's it's I think Akira toriyama's I
think who does the art for that my 90s
TV it's nine zero s my 90s tv.com and
you can it's like you turn the TV on and
it plays shows oh man that's a
commercial for friends it's like Ross is
going to ask out Rachel or something I
don't know how to watch Friends all
right
Seth weather says I didn't pay Scott to
wear that shirt but I would have ballot
Harvest 2024.
Seth weathers he did he send it to me
ballot harvesting 2024.
what do we got ready oh sorry I would
just think that'd be very popular you
know at your 90s Hotel you have like a
Rugrats room you have like a Mario party
room I think really that would be a
money maker well the idea is like it's
an apartment that looks like from the
90s you turn the TV on and it's playing
a bunch of channels like a legitimate
full channel guide of 90s shows back to
back the news everything's at five
o'clock the five o'clock news comes on
on the fridge will be like a Pizza Hut
thing when you call it it just goes to
our guys but then they'll make a pizza
for you put it in the Old School pizza
box and bring it with like some with
like RC or whatever dude if we're
talking about four player GoldenEye Man
rocket launchers in the temple that's
our proximity mines on the complex I
think well a bunch of like 50 year old
dudes
being like oh man I remember this back
in the day it's so slow when I play it
now go have you guys played golden
island did you ever play GoldenEye back
in the day oh yeah it was so fat it was
so awesome now it's real slow like
everything moves half speed and they've
just people keep thinking faster and
faster you go in the vents and you plant
the mines so when they spawn they
instantly die all right red wing
blackbird says Elon Musk didn't Vince
Foster himself I wonder I wonder what
that one means I wonder what the what
that means
that person is in the know they know
what's going on mimic says so Libs of
tick tock was set to not save for work
for sharing things happening in schools
full of children so it's not safe for
work but totally fine for kids these
people make me want to throw up
yeah
okay
rylo says hey Tim I pray you're all
right man could get a Nightly News host
only around for one show opener 1950
style dry reporting of national news
someone separate from opinion content I
get my news here
um yeah we could we're we're uh
sort of inadvertently building out a
24-hour News Channel
because uh we you know we do the show
every night eight to ten but then we
started you know pop culture crisis
Brett and Mary hosting it and they do
three to five I believe and now we're
doing
um gamer Maids at uh I think what was
that five to seven or something like
that I think so I'm not 100 sure they
chose that name and I had to say it that
way on purpose gamer comma Maids not not
gay mermaids
I love it that's the name they wanted I
don't know whatever FEMA's options
but it's awesome yeah it's because it's
they're Gamers and and they're Maids
like maidens or something I guess so
yeah maybe gamer maidens yeah
[Laughter]
but is a mermaiden like a lady mermaid
or something I don't know all right
okay
um
cat osterhout says Tim last night in the
after show you Ian and serge gave the
most beautiful beautifully balanced
scientific explanations for evolution
without excluding the Divine for the
equation thanks for the Deep dive yeah
basically last night with this really
long conversation with Bryson gray and
I'll just try and summarize I think the
position that we all had was
I believe in God there is a there is a
system in place where things are
happening and the mechanism by which God
created the universe we only understand
a tiny bit of but the formation of
universe atoms particles that's all the
structure created by God and and you you
watch it you know happen I guess at
least like we watch it happen in the
tiniest bit so you know Bryson was
saying he didn't believe in evolution he
thought that none of this could be
random but my view was like it's not
random it's God's plan it's like
everything is happening in this way that
leads to this conclusion on purpose
Fibonacci Sequence you see it in nature
a lot like this chirality of imbalance
of nature where at some point in the
growth process something will just
create a differential someone left a
great comment on timcast.com on the
video about chirality and I think when
he was saying like why does it become a
tree he was more maybe he would really
want to know how does it become a tree
and that's a question of like how is it
happening well I don't know if any of us
can really answer that all right how's
it going Eric Miller says Tim you and
Luke pushed fake news y'all said Bryson
gray was the third rapper on IRL but
you've had zooby Rucka Rucka Ali and
I've heard Alex Stein Primetime 99 has
some bars as well I demand a retracto
alpaca immediately well they're not
really rappers now I mean they're more
like commentators social media
personality no no I mean but the other
people are known just for being rappers
right Zippy's known for breaking the
women's world record no well zubi was a
was was doing rap well before any of
that so just because you heard of them
from something else they'll take away of
course and he doesn't fit in a box he's
in every man yeah and and he's got a
bunch of songs he did a song with I
didn't he worked with Bryson gray and
he's on Spotify so Rucka Rucka Ali also
fair point but we did say this in the
show we did correct and said oh yeah we
were wrong about that so um and it's not
a retracto alpaca that's a that's a
Veritas thing we have correcto which is
the uh it is the um
legally distinct version of the the
alpaca and correcto is when we make a
mistake we pull out correcto the alpaca
to admit it whereas with James O'Keefe
when he forces someone else to correct
their mistake retracto comes out to
gloat
yeah ours is derivative and a total
knockoff that's the gag there's a
there's an alpaca Farm out here and they
sell these little things you can see
it's behind the Scotland Scott yeah
okay oh some of the Woof
taking back toxic says Libs of tick tock
can sue Twitter and then Elon can fire
the Sip team for cause and terminate
their golden parachutes and pay out
damages from that but didn't he fire him
already you know fire these guys maybe
he didn't imagine Nawaz was talking
about how there's some like British
intelligence guys working at Twitter or
something like that we got to get him on
the show magic yeah he has yet to be on
IRL I think has he been on once didn't
we have him on recently he was at the
event with us at mines I don't think I
haven't seen him lately but imagine I
love I mean he's one of like one of my
great I think if there's a great friend
I've only met him a couple times or once
but I love him he's so insightful I
could have sworn we had him on but do we
not have him on yeah I think we did we
did but I want him on again I got a lot
of a lot of people on the show like four
or 500 people or something yeah crazy
a lot of people come through these doors
talon86 says so do we start a Tim pool
was right jar no
it's like I don't know man it's a coin
toss over here mostly
I'll put it this way here's what I say
you know what we get right we get right
the the the the Contemporary news
when the Covington kid things happen
thing happens we don't just pile on and
and and jump on the crowd of what was
wrong we say hold on there a minute and
we try our best to get it right that
also means people are going to call me a
milkto's fence sitter for not outright
just saying this is what happened
because I would prefer not to unless I
know for sure so sometimes we get things
right predicted predictions sometimes we
get things wrong
but usually when we're in the news we
heavily fact check and like double check
sources so we have a tendency on current
events to get it right predictions are
something totally different no one is
always always right yeah just Alex Jones
all the time no no no absolutely no no
no you mean you mean there aren't fifth
dimensional aliens who are trying to you
know there's there's more likelihood
that there probably is uh I'm just
talking about his like Julian Assange
comments before oh really what he was
opposed to was on something yeah oh wow
okay what do we got here not the bomb
says HB 5855 Illinois is trying to make
felons out of people owning assault
weapons mags greater than 10 rounds and
create registry praying Goa saves us
Goa what is it
I have no idea I don't know Gun Owners
of America oh okay all right well there
you go that's right
well then let's uh read some more
because of the Moon says first time
listener long time super chatter really
with the religious conversation
yesterday a great guest would be Ken Ham
he's president of Answers in Genesis and
the Ark Museum in Kentucky his lectures
speeches are scientific it's really cool
stuff I'm totally down for conversations
like that I love I love um philosophical
questions uh um conversations trying to
understand the universe trying to
understand faith and religion that's
that's that's the most important stuff
to me to be completely honest you know I
was last night I was looking at the full
moon speaking of spirit and I took my
glasses off and it was all blurry and I
could see the moon and I started to see
the Flower of Life in the moon do you
know the flower of life it's like this
geometric pattern it's similar to that
um but it was at first it was just five
it looked like a star in it I was like
well I see the Star of David with a big
circle in the middle it looked like a
hand with an i in it I was seeing these
amazing shapes in in the light
how much drugs were you on I was gonna
say he was completely sober during this
moment what was that story about Like
the Wolf in the sky talking to you or
something that's disturbing I um I was
meditating on my roof and I was reaching
out looking out in a space and like if
there's life out there I'm gonna drop my
magnetic field and let it experience me
and connect with me and then I felt this
Wolf Man hominid creature like a wolf
that had got a hold of psilocybin and
was uh it sensed me and it knew where I
was and I was like did I just reveal our
location to some other species that
wants to consume human flesh felt like
it and I was like well that's dangerous
as dangerous
don't drop your magnetic Shields while
beckoning out to the universe I bet it
without the proper guidance it's a
chance to be kind yeah you need to be
ready to be kind to that Force because
it's probably like a Klingon force it
will think we're an enemy and treat us
like an enemy unless we can befriend it
people in the chat think that Ian's high
but he's not
it's like a Ouija board you open the
door if you on that roof didn't close
the magnetic Shield then it's still open
I closed it okay after I felt that I was
like oh
all right let me blame you David C yeah
David C Cronk senior says Scott I'm very
proud of your work you're a role model
for today's youth here's a suggestion
ballot harvesting at churches and gun
ranges
oh I'm all over it baby and I have to
give a shout out to our East Valley
Republican women because they have this
office in uh
in the valley you know right outside of
the desert and they apparently did tens
of thousands of ballots that they had
Republicans come to the Republican
office and ballot Harvest right there so
yeah let's do it at churches let's do it
at gun shops gun shows brilliant
Joe says Tim and crew this story has
already been told in the Bible we are in
a spiritual battle against the spirit of
the age we've become a Godless Nation
it's Revival or bust call it what it is
evil the eve call it what it is evil
then mock it relentlessly
yeah there's a lot of evil man I'm
concerned that that we don't
overcompensate against what we think is
evil because if if you get too extreme
with what you think is good it can
become another form of evil
see Mac says oath Breakers cops broke
oath to their Community that's right
maybe I'll put that in the billboard
beware dirty cops AKA oath Breakers
I think just beware dirty cops with
their picture is probably sufficient
you know they're dirty cops man
you're a dirty cop
all right
Midas says the time of blatantly
supporting cops is over so many are just
extensions of a Draconian Elite no
longer are they members of the community
instead of assuming the best and
defending them let's hold them
accountable
here's my thing
I'm not going to play a stupid game
where I'm like you know young got a cab
or anything like that because I have
cops that are that help me to the best
of their abilities it's just that their
abilities are limited and so uh these
cops are cool there are bad cops a lot
of them and the system in big cities is
completely broken and in a place like
Fredericksburg where you know it's just
the latest iteration of the story the
other story we saw was the was the blind
guy in Florida
the lady cop was like what is that and
he's like it's my walking cane and then
she basically arrests him because he
told her to f off
like these are dirty cops
and I'm sick of it and something's got
to be done about it
so these these police officers that
break their oath to the Constitution and
spit in the faces of the people who
wanted to back the blue need to be
reminded that ain't nobody gonna be
backing you if you trample on those who
are actually supporting you so so long
as no one actually wants to call them
out the cops are going to be like I can
do whatever I want because conservatives
are too stupid to say anything about it
and the left hates me anyway dude like
local cops if they disagree with these
edicts do they just get together like in
private a bunch of like just of the
officers and say we're gonna go to
supervisor and just refuse sir we're not
we're not doing it
I've heard stories of them being like
you can't tell me I won't do that and
then they just get a different cop to go
do it so they really need a union of of
everybody well or they need people to
finally be like hey we're not going to
tolerate this well officers also have
discretion and they decide you know how
they're going to be implementing a lot
of the things that they're told to
implement so it looked like a gormel it
was like State Police it was like a
couple of States two different it would
look like local land State that's that's
a that's a way around so uh there's a
clear shot of all their faces thanks to
that video and I'm going to take
screenshots and we're going to put up a
billboard and I'll put them up I'll put
them as much as far as I can it's gonna
be it'll it'll be moderately expensive
but it will feel really really good to
do if anything if that's all I get out
of it is some kind of emotional
satisfaction then you know that's good
enough for me now what else am I going
to do complain on the internet about it
that works too well I was thinking about
I was like what if we just did like a
segment where it's like we dedicate a
week to you know calling out
people doing bad things being a
politician or I I don't just rag on Cops
for the sake of right now cops that's
stupid like in this instance we have bad
cops but there's a ton of bad
politicians and then I'm like yeah but
the people who watch this show they know
right how do we reach new people yeah to
put up a billboard is I'll call up my uh
my Ad Agency and say like what do you
what have you got in Fredericksburg and
the surrounding suburbs and then we'll
put up a bunch of billboards with these
cops faces on it and then when uh they
go out to eat one day some guy's gonna
go hey you're that dirty cop I saw in on
on 95 they're gonna go what like yeah
you're the dirty cop you're a dirty cop
and they're gonna be like why are you
calling me that because your face is on
billboards all over town because you did
something
that'll feel really good I've always
been in the mindset of like work with
law enforcement because what else do we
have you snitch and then I'm like when
you learn about the Nazis and how they
they use law enforcement to just
annihilate people we should have a
bonehead of the week award and the
person who wins the award gets uh to be
put on the billboard right I mean that
could be something that we could
brainstorm together and be like hey the
worst person this week was
and then we could have the award and we
could give them an actual award it could
be like it could be like a dirty sock
um well we we uh we recently acquired a
building for the new Cafe that we're
putting up it's happening remember I've
been talking about wanting to do this
coffee house it's happening that's why I
said we're going to be selling coffee we
have a we have a coffee brand
everything's getting set up but the
building's there I wonder if I could put
a big billboard on it yeah you probably
can and then you know I don't know about
once a week but once a month you know
bonehead of the month yeah and then just
slap their thing up on a big billboard
in the middle of town there's probably a
better creative name that we could think
of uh for this bag yeah dirt bag's
pretty good I like that one too
it's got to be alliterative if it was a
daily it was a digital billboard we
could do the daily dirt bag yeah that
sounds good daily dirt bag but no but
you need them to be up there longer than
a week so um what's a W word that's
derisive wacko wacko nah but it's got to
imply like I'm not I'm not so he's
weiner head weirdest wiener head
Wednesday I'm not concerned about
weirdos or or wackos I'm concerned about
the corrupt dirt bags which come back
Wicked there you go that's a good one
the wiki weekly Wicked award
nah Wicked sounds too cool
that's true right weasel would be like I
won yeah Weasley weasel award it needs
to be have it needs to have more oof the
people will will figure this out for us
yeah I'm not a big fan of the gigantic
piece of human crap award and then it's
a steaming crap that we put on their
head and billboard
just big big crap head
due to head dirt bag award
what are people giving suggestions
weekly wuss was one of them Tyrant of
the week yep weasels weekly weasels
all right Vinyl cover 1987 says Tim I'm
a detective in a major metropolitan area
in Texas and I'm getting less and less
back the blue despite solving on violent
crime cases hope Luke doesn't hate me
Ian you're cool rock and roll I don't
hate you man but uh you know
yeah like hates the wrong word loath is
probably better who was that that's a
cop in Texas yeah a detective he's
saying it's it's been rough lately
sentiment a lot of people are given
money saying do the billboard do the
billboard do the billboard uh it really
just depends on look you know I said I
want to do it people give me super chats
just keep in mind
I might not be able to the billboard
agency might be like no no no we're not
going to get involved in this they
probably won't because money talks and
Bs walks they usually just say I'll send
it up the chains see what they say and a
lot of the Billboards on highways and in
cities that are just Standalone
Billboards are owned by those companies
and they will take money for basically
anything I've been getting a lot of
private messages from police officers
who are like please don't hate me
essentially saying that I don't hate you
guys if there's a good officer that
actually does help the community and
does good you guys are awesome you guys
deserve help you guys deserve to be
complimented but when an officer does
something wrong and abuses their
position of power they deserve to be
called out so I I know not to judge but
uh you know we got to call a spade a
spade here and the only way to root out
the bad people is to call out the bad so
that's what I'm trying to do here I
don't hate any of you guys do you think
it would work right do you think that
these cops in the Fredericksburg
metropolitan area if we put up like 15
Billboards do you think they would see
that and start sweating bullets being
like oh man I really shouldn't be doing
this yeah absolutely and it would make
them you know think twice about their
discretion and how they use their
authority over the people and and what
they're going to be doing next time
because obviously there's no way an
average person could look at the
situation and be like yeah the cops did
the right thing there because they
didn't they didn't do the right thing
they have no Sanctuary with the left
none there's not going to be a
circumstance where a cop goes to a bunch
of leftists and says the right the
antibacters are yelling at me they're
gonna laugh and be like go cry somewhere
else except for j6 right of course when
they get an award yes but you know good
luck going to leftist activists as a cop
and being like will you please serve me
a cheeseburger the right's mad at me
because of covid lockdown stuff they're
going to be like screw off you white
supremacist well I think it's similar to
I've been listening to people say
you know the left uh no I mean excuse me
corporations know that the right is
always going to have their back right
and do tax breaks or whatever or support
them and so therefore they pandered to
the left because they know they'll
always have the support of the right and
it's kind of like the the black
community the left knows that the
majority of black citizens are going to
vote Democratic and so therefore they
don't really have to do anything to make
the black community happy because they
know that the majority of black citizens
are going to vote for them regardless
and so the only way to have neutrality
or to have police or corporations or
politicians actually fight for us as if
we move away from
uh being left or right but going towards
the center because then everybody is
going to have to earn our support and I
think that would actually make Society
much safer and more Equitable I don't
want to forget so I literally just
texted my uh my ad agent like the
absolute person it's like it's a
different company it's not our company
it's like the person who does the sales
I just literally texted them like you
got any inventory in Fredericksburg I
don't want to forget because I think we
have to do it maybe we acknowledge a
some an officer that did really well too
so you're bashing the people that should
be bashed and then you're acknowledging
it's hard to do and it's really
expensive right but uh not a bad idea my
thing is do we offer a path of
redemption first like apologize to this
man and say you were wrong
otherwise we're going to call you out
for being a dirty cop
I think
I think that would be a reasonable way
to start first see if there's any
remorse for what they did but if they're
like no I did the right thing I didn't
do anything wrong and I'm gonna do it
again if in the same situation then yes
billboard baby I think probably just to
be clean safe and make sure everything's
above board you're a bad cop you do
something bad I put up a billboard
non-profit yeah like let you could
fundraise it probably why don't you know
what I should do so so a lot of people
have asked about the fact checking
nonprofit because it was like two years
ago I said we're gonna do this thing and
everyone's like yeah right and I'm like
we're gonna do it uh it takes like
almost like two and a half years to get
certified and get all the paperwork and
everything so the company exists but
we're waiting for a non-profit
certification because we're trying to
get a 501c3 not a C4 this means it can't
be political it's just going to do facts
checking it's in the works it exists the
paperwork has been filed it just takes
forever it would be great to do the same
thing uh you know fundraising to put up
Billboards to call out people who do bad
things we would take submissions from
you know the donors like who do you
think is a person of political power who
has acted improperly send us videos and
there could be videos of cops doing bad
things videos of politicians doing bad
things and then we raise money just to
put up Billboards the ad agent the ad
industry they will love us because
Billboards are rather ineffective these
days and they struggle to sell the
inventory because people are like I can
buy on Facebook I get it right there on
their phone I don't need to be up there
but this will get everyone talking about
it right and there'll be a lot of media
reports and this means the billboard
companies are gonna are gonna have
guaranteed sales and they're going to be
like whatever brings money into our
industry in a dying you know medium
so I think that's a that's a good idea
all right let's just go grab one more
all right Miguel Alvera says Serge did a
great job last night in the members only
show perfectly explained what many of us
were thinking I agree I think he did a
much better job than I
um but uh you know
religious conversations can be
frustrating sometimes but I think
they're absolutely awesome so if you
haven't already would you kindly smash
that like button subscribe to this
channel share this show with your
friends become a member over at
timcast.com head over to timcast.com
right now click join us sign up we're
gonna have a members only show coming up
for you should be live around 11 p.m and
uh it's usually not so family friendly
and a little bit spicy you can follow
the show at timcastirl on Instagram we
have Clips you can follow me personally
at timcast everywhere and go follow at
timcast news on Twitter because uh we
had a lot eliahu he's our ground
reporter at the New York Times during
the strike filming all the stuff and he
routinely goes out and asks real
questions of these people he doesn't do
anything that gotcha stuff no none of
that phony make make a person look dumb
he actually asked the New York Times
Union some legitimate questions about
their concerns you can really learn from
this stuff plus we post our stories
Scott do you want to shout anything out
yeah I just wanted to see what I'm going
to be working on very briefly for the
future you know I just came back from
Georgia disappointing results but you
know that's not going to keep us from
moving forward so here are my goals uh
for anybody that's more politically
minded I am working to make sure that we
have new leadership at the Republican
National Committee uh I think six years
of losses under our current chairwoman
means it's time for change and that's
why I'm endorsing and supporting harmeet
Dylan for the next RNC uh chairwoman
position and she's already indicated
that one of her first roles would be to
hire somebody like me and of course I'd
want to look at the stipulations and
what would be contingent on my working
for such an organization but that shows
understanding that it's important to
bring in the Grassroots and to not only
look at the Consulting class or listen
to the big donors but listen to us
listen to the people it's pure populism
give the people what they want and
immediately I'm already working towards
is going to Louisiana
and Kentucky to flip those governorships
from Blue to red as well as working on
my state of Virginia to make sure that
with Governor Glenn yonkin if we take
the state senate if we take the house of
delegates we're going to be able to pass
legislation at the state level to Buck
against the federal government because
all these conversations we're having are
wonderful but we need to actually
Implement those policies into law to
affect real change and I'm also going to
be focusing on Jersey so if anybody's
interested in helping please slide into
my DMs in the most wholesome of manner
and you can find me at Scott Pressler
s-c-o-t-t-p-r-e-s-l-e-r I'm also on true
social get or telegram Facebook gab and
parlor Andy no tweeted something out
about a half an hour ago that I have to
mention before we go that's the uh
Twitter's head of the head of Twitter
strategic Response Team guess where he
worked immediately before Twitter
FBI United States Marine Corps
intelligence and guess where he worked
and guess who he assisted
um partially during his his tenure
James Comey the CIA and the FBI and then
immediately after leaving those roles he
gets a job at Twitter wow so if you want
to shout anything out oh imagine the
coincidence that happened there uh thank
you stuxenhammer for coming on the show
I really appreciate that uh sorry I had
to that's the hair you're awesome uh
Scott that was that was a great
conversation thank you so much for
coming on what was your Twitter again at
Scott Pressler thank you so much uh my
YouTube channel is we are change uh
YouTube is not showing anyone the video
I did today I worked very hard on it I
talked about a lot of the crazy AI stuff
a lot of the stuff happening
geopolitically check it out youtube.com
forward slash we are change and I'll be
there talking to you guys in the chat if
you don't know the stocks and Hammer
references Styx hex and Hammer 666 the
YouTuber political you know I know who
that is yes beautiful hair he's
supported on some of my work and I'm
just glad by the way that I was not on
that episode of Tim pool because I saw
that and it was 666 I was like um
yeah that was a wonderful week hey
thanks for coming again Scott always
great to see you man thank you and now
whenever I see the moon
I'm gonna think of you seeing the Flower
of Life meditating in a wolf spirit and
it's just it's gonna do it for me from
now on for the rest of my life open up
your field align your chakras you have
good posture uh Kellen tell me about the
evening what's up man
um hey Scott it was great to meet you it
was a great conversation had a lot of
fun tonight
um you can find everyone watching you
can find me at Kellen PDL I'm mostly
active on Twitter again I was filling in
for search
um I don't know if he'll be back
tomorrow but hopefully he will
um but yeah thanks guys we will see you
all over at timcast.com thanks for
hanging out